biohazard container location on methi
Paget aka Ronald McDonald hey how's it
going
and Jake Decker okay bong waters 69
what's up loser okay we according to
Forbes magazine us three are the best
three siege players in the world as far
as I can match go so I figured we get
together and the span of one match recap
2019 talk about our hopes for 2020 give
Ubisoft a few pointers for how to make
their game better because obviously if
there's one thing we all know it's
intense game design and development so
first off man
while we're breaching oh and also I
should add we're gonna try to play well
while we do it
we're on Clubhouse right now this is not
a new map but it was riemann reworked a
couple of years ago so we figured what
the hell it's also a fun map
okay Matt 2019 give me a rating out of
10 for the game and then justify it I
think it's me
I think they made a lot of smart changes
to operators and maps and I loved the
events like showdown
so definitely an eighth for me they
might be in the money room oh I'm out
okay Jake what about you 2019 what do
you think I would say seven for me I
love this game please came a lot but I
the battery works are great but I wish
there were at least one other new map
and I wasn't super wild about most the
operators they're cool I love the
designs of them but I think actually
playing them I kind of I kind of just
play the original it's mostly like
season 1 stuff co2 7 yeah I you know
what I feel like
this year's operators aren't as crucial
as those in years past they feel more
supplemental a cure the vibe and I don't
know how much of an impact
made it live day to day see oh nice
speaking of new I bury those collie so I
do want to talk about really quick I
guess
wait what hold on watch this oh that's
right I forgot I killed the guy to win
the match
ground people have been again this Ally
this is both minority but I mean like
it's hard not to notice how wacky the
characters have been getting and
Farfetch'd they've been getting people
are saying it's like in danger of oh
it's not gonna be a tactical shooter if
they keep doing that like is that dooms
they speak or is there something there
uh I think it's doomsday speak but it's
not something we should ignore I do
think I love the themes like I love how
like kind of goofy some of the
characters have been this year like nook
and like even go back to doe could be or
this year as well my is a goofy concept
and I love that but like I said the
abilities haven't really blown me away
and just don't feel as crucial as like
you can never go wrong with thermit I
can't really say that about any operator
this year yeah I I mean Burt horizon I
think we all agree was the best
expansion last year not just because it
was the only one that added a new map as
opposed to map reworks which are pretty
self-explanatory I don't know that we
need to get into all that much watch out
they might be peeking on pink from
desert clear unless that was us there it
looks like they're peeking on like every
window on the second floor but again
that many of us want to breach you Oh
God
I'm not going in that way the long way
around
dan I'm jammed Oh hon let me go over
here yeah will it destroy my thermite
thing go take it off I mean I got the
left side yeah I mean like the other
thing too right is like a lot of these
maps were designed with those original
operators in mind right like those
operators were key in order for those
maps and these strategies to work and
now as matt said all of the operators
feel more supplemental or like kind of
tweaks on other off like you know like
obviously there's a lot of breachers and
like it just kind of depends on what
kind of breaching style you want to use
right I'm out further I'm all further
ridiculousness how are you guys doing
right now you dead yep mind dad
you and Jake is still alive mute is in
the garage hostile activity resumed
securing the container once the threat
is neutralized
cookie what you say you want good
footage but you gotta I just realize
it's match smash point so we might need
to get through a few topics namely team
killing okay
speaking of seis you see I got reverse
friendly fire and then you can see when
you try to report someone they've got
griefing voice abuse cheating or hacking
abuse a chat they've just made it more
robust Jake you and I did a video a
couple years ago about how they've been
trying to battle toxic players like any
multiplayer game as I guess I think the
interesting thing about this age which
is why they're having so much trouble
with it is that like team killing is her
friendly fire is an important part of
this game I feel like you'd get rid of
that you would that would be an issue so
it's really tough to balance that right
and I think they've done about as much
as they can do with it okay things are
getting tense in this round but I'm
still gonna go make things interesting
20 20 what do you hope what are your
hopes for it Matt I would love to see
more operator more boring death operator
reworks I loved what they did with glass
changing the way his scope works and
honestly I would love to see them go
more in depth with maybe some rarely
picked operators like to chunka I think
that'd be really interesting don't
change table Maya that's my thing don't
change too chunka no no I would say more
Maps
I think it'd be nice to bring back or
rework Bartlett University as well like
I know that map was kind of broken
especially for spawn peaks and whatnot
but I did like that map and I'd like
them to bring that back in also nice
some of these maps that they really
reworked like your fruit base I would
love to like a classic throwback
playlist for a while or something where
I can just play like oh dang
Frank you should play like ogee your
fruit base cuz personally I like that
one even more even though I notice I'll
give you my hopes
right after I kill this guy nice can I
kill it there introducing the siege
universe I guess the last thing I'll get
in right now they're introducing the
siege universe which from that new CGI
trailer and I want them to go all-in
with that I'm a huge [ __ ] siege Laura
nerd and I want more of it and it
reminds me of when a book gets made into
a movie I'm like oh I'm gonna do this
character the CGI trailer were like
these characters have existed in my head
for so long that I just really want to
see what you'd be Montreal on the siege
universe team quote-unquote does with
them and again I know that's geeky but I
don't care I hope they go all in with it
it's not just like a half-assed attempt
but anyway guys thanks for joining me uh
of course we would go 3 no we were
I mean Forbes doesn't lie and that was
definitely definitely definitely the
first time we attempted this recording
tonight and I won't hear any evidence to
the contrary over here this here has
been interest speak
and I kind of enjoy this I know they
complained the last several years has
been they've been getting too much into
crowd control abilities there's a
perfect example of why a marui is fun
but not always I don't even think that's
a good example how she's fun I had